[Music]
it's being dubbed the trip of several
lifetimes and has attracted millions of
applicants the galaxy over but can the
Andromeda initiative really succeed
after nine years of preparation the
Andromeda initiative is mere days away
from launch the project the brainchild
of jen gerson plans to send tens of
thousands of the galaxy's explorers
scientists and colonists 2.5 million
light-years across the universe this 600
year journey will take these intrepid
pioneers in to truly uncharted territory
namely the Helius cluster of the
Andromeda galaxy but what do we know
about Andromeda first observed in 964
siiii the Andromeda galaxy also known as
m31 is the closest major galaxy two
hours and the most distant thing visible
with a naked eye from Earth and
approximately two hundred and twenty
thousand light-years across its wars'
the Milky Way and contains at least
twice the number of stars beyond such
broad facts however it remains a
fascinating mystery the initiative was
conceived after long range scans
suggested the presence of golden worlds
the name given to potentially habitable
resource-rich planets but is that enough
to warrant a journey of this scale and
costs not to mention the loss of some of
the galaxy's most talented individuals
according to alec Ryder the answer is a
resounding yes if the names familiar it
should be he was one of the first humans
to travel through the Sharan mass relay
his fierceness in 2149 helped bring
earth and the rest of the Milky Way
together and once again he is stepping
into the unknown with a hope of bringing
two entire galaxies together in fact he
has so much faith in the project that
he's bringing his twin children along
for the ride in his new role as
pathfinder for the ark Hyperion his role
will be to combine his n7 training vast
scientific knowledge and rich
exploration experience to find and
assess the potential golden worlds but
even rider will admit that nobody not
even a man whose reputation is built on
braving the unfamiliar has any idea what
awaits them on arrival nor can anybody
guarantee that the impressive arc ships
constructed for the journey will survive
the trip whatever the outcome it will
always mark a pivotal moments in our
efforts to expand our understanding of
the
you